scene 1 all right all right take three
marker defense calls Colonel Nathan
Jessup all right all right all right
let's do this would you state your name
rank and current billet for the record
please sir Colonel Nathan R just
commanding officer and Academy Award
winner thank you sir did you wear that
uniform on the plane no lieutenant I
prefer to fly shirtless or having no
earthly bond beneath my feet
plus I like being shirtless freud's
having this meeting you gave lieutenant
Kendrick an order is that right that's
right that's right that's right I told
him to always take the long way when the
bulu
blocks your path can you explain it I
told him it takes three to tango
especially in Barcelona and did you give
an order to Colonel Markinson as well I
told him JKL just keep living and that
president Colonel Markinson is dead is
that right oh whoa that's a bit of it
down hey everybody okay if I take off my
shirt part of the mourning process did
you order the Code Red
it is code red to remove my shirt I'm
gonna put stuffing this hey I'm sorry a
hole is that sort of mouth adjuster
did you order the Code Red hey you
better lighten up you want a pup I think
I'm entitled won't me get you what the
truth all right here's two did you order
the Code Red
did I mention I want an Academy Award